[Musique]
bonjour david vous allez suivre cette
mobilisation aujourd'hui à quoi faut-il
s'attendre et doit-on craindre dans un
futur proche à un manque d'effectifs
notamment dans les établissements de
santé selon vous
et bien magali est dans la lignée un des
manifestations anti pas sanitaire de
nombreuses personnes devraient se réunir
ici devant le ministère de la santé à
partir de 11h objectif contesti
l'obligation vaccinale mais aussi les
sanctions qui sont mises en place pour
répondre à vos questions concernant le
manque d'effectifs dans les
établissements de santé eh bien c'est
très aléatoire finalement puisque ça
dépend du domaine 1 malgré les chiffres
avancés par santé publique france qui
affirme qu au 7 septembre un peu plus de
88% un des soignants ont reçu au moins
une dose de vaccin est bien dans le
détail l inquiétude demeure notamment
pour les ehpad la déléguée générale de
la fédération hospitalière de france
reconnaît que les établissements eux
mêmes n'ont pas de vue exhaustive sur le
statut vaccinal de leurs agents autre
domaine est très touché les ambulanciers
une personne sur dix ne souhaiterait pas
se faire vacciner elle dans ce domaine
là le risque d'une rupture de soins est
envisagé et coûté
13 % de la profession ne seraient pas
vaccinés et ne souhaiterait pas l'être
on risque d'avoir de véritables
difficultés avec une rupture du parcours
de soins des patients et une
augmentation de la carence ambulancière
c'est à dire des refus d'intervention
pour le compte du samu et donc devoir
faire des choix douloureux entre urgence
et transport programme est justement de
la ville c'est sur ce point précis que
la cgt s'inquiète et le syndicat prévoit
une possible catastrophe sanitaire
une possible fuite du personnel
effectivement qui pourrait avoir des
conséquences non négligeables sur les
hôpitaux français même son cloche pour
la cfdt fo santé qui réclament un délai
supplémentaire pour rappel les
restrictions rentreront en vigueur dès
demain et cela concerne près de deux
millions sept cent mille personnes ceux
qui n'auront pas reçu au moins une dose
de vaccin pourront être suspendues sans
rémunération les soignants et qui
manifestent depuis le mois de juin
dénonce une mesure antidémocratique
écouter
mais vous vous rendez compte de ce que
ces quatre soignantes me les a sûrement
des sacs mortuaires qui est dans la
maltraitance institutionnelle qui
souffre dans son travail et à qui on dit
barroso je vais juste continuer comme ça
et puis que toi vacciner les bisons se
fait pas vacciner
sera suspendu sans salaire mais quel
pays démocratique fait 500 et 500c juste
ignoble
à droite la confiance
connaissance et beaucoup de crainte
également malgré sa l'exécutif ne
lâchera pas oublier vers ans s'est
montré intransigeant concernant les
fraudes notamment les arrêts maladie
promettant des contrôles systématiques
pour toute prescription jugée suspecte
vous l'aurez compris la mobilisation
devrait être au rendez-vous aujourd'hui
devant le ministère de la santé afin de
faire pression sur le gouvernement mais
aussi sur le ministre de la santé merci
beaucoup david pour toutes ces
précisions et on va suivre évidemment
cette mobilisation tout au long de la
journée